[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previous
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact every time a jet plane
lands you see a little puff of white
smoke as the wheels make contact with a
the ground this is because each tire
leaves about 1 and 1/2 lbs of burnt
rubber on the runway aircraft tires are
stationary until touchdown when the
sudden contact with the ground causes
tremendous friction quickly whipping
them up to speeds of more than 150 mph
and producing temperatures of around
500° fah jumbo planes like the Airbus
380 with 22 tires leave as much as 30
lbs of rubber on the runway with each
Landing in case you're wondering a jet
tire is only good for about 200 Landings
before it needs to be retreaded or
replaced as you might guess this rapid
buildup of rubber can make runways very
slick when wet at larger airports
specializ Crews must go out at night
three or four times weekly to remove
hundreds of pounds of excess tire rubber
from the runways and clean it from the
runway lights it's estimated that 10,000
lb of aircraft tire rubber is removed
from US airports runways
annually you probably seen that Pastor
Ross when the planes come in you see a
big poof when they first make contact
that's right you know you always wonder
why don't they figure out a way to turn
the tires but I guess they're going to
have to spin them real fast to get 150
miles or whatever it is to touch down
without the the puff of smoke but yeah
it's sort of thing I thought maybe they
could find some air pressure to get them
spinning so there's not so much friction
when they make contact but um yeah I'm
glad that they they clean off the mhm
the rubber every now and then and you
know they have to wait until the last
planes come in at night you know
sometimes might be 2 in the morning then
the crew gets out there real quick and
the lights on and they clean off the
Runway and get it ready for the next day
or next few days and it just reminded me
that you know as we go through this life
uh even though we come to the Lord and
we've accepted Jesus and we're baptized
and our sins are washed away sometimes
we need a
a refreshing we need to be re cleansed
and U you know Jesus actually
established something at the Last Supper
where he washed the disciples feet and
he said you know not only are we to
remember the Lord's death and sacrifice
through the communion of the bread and
the grape juice but Jesus said if I your
Lord and Master have washed your feet
you ought to wash one another's feet and
um so it's like a mini baptism
but it makes me think of that verse that
if we confess our sins and this is 1
John
1:9 if we confess our sins he is
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness so we're cleansed by
coming to the Lord we repent and we
confess our sins but then why do we need
baptism well you know you mentioned
Pastor the communion or the foot washing
is a miniature baptism but the Bible's
clear that when one receives Christ as
he personal savior he needs to make a
public profession of that and that is
through baptism Jesus said except a man
be born of water and of the spirit
cannot enter the kingdom of of God so
that public confession of our faith to
be baptized by immersion following the
example of Jesus it's an important step
and it's a it's a wonderful step for the
one being baptized it's a new beginning
it's cleansing from the past you can
claim the promise of the verse you just
read that if we confess our sins Christ
will forgive us and cleanse us and you
come up out of the water and you have a
new walk with Christ it's an exciting
experience and then the U when we have
the Lord's Supper communion and even
foot washing that's sort of like
cleaning the runway every now and then
that's right well I think we have a free
offer that talks about it's one of the
amazing fact study guides and it's
called Purity and power and this is a
free gift to anyone who is listening all
you need to do is call the number 800
6747 and ask for offer number 121 and
we'll be happy to send that to you
that's 8835 6747 ask for the book it's
called Purity and power it's actually
part of our amazing fact Study Guide
Series or another way to get it is
simply by dialing pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible answers live and
then ask for the gift we'll be happy to
send it to you but let's begin this
broadcast with prayer then we have other
exciting announcements to share along
the way all right let's start with
prayer dear father once again we are
grateful for the opportunity to be able
to open up your word and study as we
always do Lord we ask for your presence
to be with us here in the studio and
also be with those who are listening if
they're in their car or at home wherever
they might be and Lord lead us to a
clear understanding of Truth for the
Bible says you sh the truth and the
truth will set you free thank you for
your promise to be with us in jesus'
name amen amen well we're ready to go to
the phone lines our first caller this
evening is calling from Texas we got
Jerry in Texas Jerry welcome to the
program hey thanks uh you know science
always is tries to outdo God are we able
is science able to look back in time the
days of Hezekiah when the sun was turned
back
10° you know I I was thinking about that
and uh I don't know that science would
be able to do it because you know what
markers would they have in the sky that
would demonstrate that um I was
wondering it was there any historical
account because Hezekiah he lived what
700 BC you would think maybe there was
some other Nation now it does say in the
Bible that the um the Magi in Babylon
noticed it of course everyone noticed it
and they actually sent emissaries to
find out about the wonder that had been
done so in the Bible it says other
nations took note of it but I don't know
of extra Biblical history where it's
mentioned I mean God can do anything but
if you stop the Earth spinning on its on
its axis for that period of time and
then started it up again there would be
nothing in nature to um indicate that
other than just the long day that the
people had when they were there yeah
people would say well that was a really
long day I know I've had those
days so I it'd be hard to find Jerry I
haven't heard of anything but um I might
poke around on the internet and see if
there's anything in history next caller
that we have is Lois from Florida Lois
welcome to the program hello pastors how
you doing oh it's Louis
sorry yes and your question my question
is for from Revelation
21:4 the ending where it says the former
things have passed away how much are we
to actually remember like our families
or or anything like that do we remember
anything well I think when it says uh
the former things have passed away uh
it's telling us that uh all the painful
memories will be gone God is going to
wipe away our tears I think that not
only are we hurt by painful events we
often are hurt when we remember them and
you know you can see tears coming to a
person's eye eyes when they talk about
someone they love that passed away
they're just visiting that in their mind
and it brings pain um but I think that
God is going to cleanse us from the
painful memories and it's not that he's
going to brainwash us I think our minds
are going to be so filled with the glory
of the future that we won't be looking
back it's like Paul says forgetting
those things that are behind I press on
and God wants his people to be Forward
Thinking once you repent of your sins
you leave them there God buries them in
the depths of the sea we move forward
and you know that's true even in life
today people have gone through some
difficult experiences but the pain does
wear off to some degree and here the
promise in the new Earth uh those
painful experiences or memories will
eventually fade away and there'll be
nothing to take away from the joy and
just the worship the experience of being
eternally in heaven amen all right thank
you for your call next next qu that we
have is Gary listening in Illinois Gary
welcome to the
program thank you my question is about
our covenant with God I know the first
one was circumcision and then the Ten
Commandments but now Jesus in Matthew 26
verse 28 says this is the blood of the
New Covenant which is shed for the many
for the Forgiveness of sins so to
understand that I I go to 1 John first9
if we confess our sins he's faithful and
just to forgive us our sin and cleanse
us from all unrighteousness so the New
Covenant is Jesus forgiving sin in view
of sanctification am I right no one is
saved by the law in the Old Testament
they were saved by faith in the old
Covenant though it talks about God made
an agreement with his people where he
said here's my law and the people said
all the Lord has said we will do but
they broke the law almost immediately
they made a golden calf and then God
said in Jeremiah IAH he said I'll make a
New Covenant with the house of Israel
I'll write my law on their hearts now
the covenants were all sealed with blood
in the Old Testament the old Covenant
was sealed with a symbol for Christ's
blood it was the blood of a lamb that's
why when Jesus got baptized John the
Baptist said this is the Lamb of God
that takes away the sin of the world and
so Jesus is basically saying the New
Covenant it's not based on the Lamb's
blood it's based on the Precious Blood
of the Son of God yes and it's through
that we're both Justified and Sanctified
as you mentioned through faith in that
our sins are forgiven and we walk in a
newness of life so hopefully that helps
you know we have a a really good book
that I think you'd enjoy and it talks
about that that Covenant it's a sermon
book and I think it's got a Little Lamb
on the cover and talks about the The
Plan of Salvation and what that New
Covenant is and if You' like we'll be
happy to send you a copy of that Gary
and you call and ask for the book on the
uh new the New Covenant a matter of fact
here it is it's called blood behind the
veil it's called a lamb on the COV
that's probably the one you're thinking
of okay uh that's the free offer we'll
be happy to send it to anyone wanting to
learn more about the New Covenant it's
called blood behind the veil and uh to
call just uh to get it just call the
number 800 835 6747 you can ask for the
book it's called blood behind the veil
or doll pound 250 on your smartphone say
Bible answers live ask for that by name
blood behind the veil and we'll be happy
to say to you all right next caller that
we have is Philip listening to Arkansas
Philip you're on Bible answers
live hi thank you my question is in
Revelation 14 after the Three Angels
messages you get to verse
13 and it
says blessed are the Dead who die in the
Lord from now on so my question is
what's different about those who die in
the Lord after the Three Angels messages
versus those who have always died in the
Lord yeah good question you know I think
it's is referring to a time of trouble
that is coming upon the Earth according
to Daniel CH 12 it says when Michael
stands up there will be a time of
trouble worse than the world has ever
seen uh we know that um God's people
will be protected during that time but
it's still going to be a difficult time
for for a lot of people I mean you got
the seven last plagues that are pouring
out there's a lack of food the water is
turning to blood you can just read the
description that it it has there and
here is sort of a a blessing pronounced
upon those who have faith in God they
are lay to rest blessed before the final
time of trouble their reward is in
heaven and it's true everyone who's died
in faith they are blessed but in the
context of the last days and the events
that are taking place there's actually a
blessing for those who are laid to rest
before the final events occur that's
right yeah and I think I was looking for
the verse it's in Isaiah where it says
that none considers that some of the
people that die are saved from the Wrath
that come mhm and back in Isaiah that he
knew the Babylonian captivity was coming
he says those that die before that it's
going to be a blessing and before the
great time of trouble and which you find
in Revelation 14 as you say it's going
to be a blessing for those to go to
sleep and not have to experience that
does that help
philli yeah that makes sense I
appreciate it thanks next caller that we
have is uh Anna listening in Oregon Anna
welcome to the
program evening
pastors my question tonight is who are
the 24 El and Revelation are they Elders
that were
resurrected when after Jesus or are they
beings from other planets well there are
two theories uh I'll tell you what one
theory is that you know when Christ died
and rose again actually it says when he
died there was an earthquake and many
graves were opened and some of the SL
Saints or many of the saints that slept
around Jerusalem were raised and
ascended to heaven with him some have
thought well maybe those 24 for elders
are composed of some of the saints that
were buried around Jerusalem that came
forth with Christ um that would be a
pretty narrow sample of the people that
God would put around the throne uh the
other Theory and this is probably the
one I ascribe to is that the Bible tells
us in job there was a day when the sons
of God came to present themselves before
the Lord sons of God and they are like
the leaders of unfallen Worlds Adam was
called the Son of God and he was to have
dominion of this world but he gave it to
the devil so instead of Adam showing up
Satan comes to this heavenly meeting
again I'm talking about Job chapter 1
and so it's been believed that you know
these 24 Elders are really
representatives of God's unfallen Cosmos
out there that have come it's also a
play on what you see when I say play on
it's like there's a symbol in the Old
Testament you read where both David and
Solomon they had leadership that
surrounded them in the number of 24
which is of course 12 * 12 it's
symbolizing you know God's leadership in
heaven yeah maybe just one more thing on
that Pastor Isaiah 24:23 this the Old
Testament it says the Lord shall reign
before his Elders gloriously yeah and
that's the Old Testament yeah and uh you
read in Revelation chapter 4 you have
the 24 Elders that are already in heaven
and Christ doesn't appear until chapter
5 and so they're already in heaven
waiting for Jesus and he appears is the
lamb as it it means late so it appears
as though these Elders as you said are
representatives of the unfallen worlds
and there they are that great Council
that are witnessing the uh Cosmic
conflict between Christ and Satan all
right next caller that we have is Glenn
listening in Ohio Glenn welcome to the
program thank you for taking my call
gentlemen I have a word in my mind a
religious word but at a Bible study one
night a couple years ago I asked the
question and everybody giggled until
nobody could give an answer to the
question the word you see it with a
definite article only you never see it
with a indefinite article you see it as
an
adverb as a noun as a direct object but
I don't know what the word means or what
it is can you help me the word is
Glory Glory I think I can uh you find
the word glory in the Bible many times
and uh it's talking about matter of fact
I'm looking right now and it says
379 times it appears when you think of
Glory think of something that is bright
but in the Bible context it's not just
bright it's a symbol of holy
Splendor and so you've got this
brilliant holy Splendor around the Lord
and um it says when Moses came down from
the mountain after talking to God his
face was shining and then Paul talks
about you know the glory
that Moses had was so bright he veiled
his face but how much more glorious is
Christ um and you have a lot of examples
of this but I think the word may be used
a few different ways but that's probably
the most prominent you've got the glory
as you mentioned the glory of God this
there's power there presence the Bible
speaks of that but then the Bible also
tells us to give God glory so not only
does God have glory in and of himself
but we can give him glory and the way we
do that is to live a life that brings
honor to his name to be obedient to what
he asks us to do we are giving glory to
God whether you eat or drink or whatever
you do do it to the glory of God right
the first Angel's message in Revelation
14 says fear God and give him glory so
it's more than just the Glorious
presence of God but it's actually
willing obedience that is part of giving
glory and even with our mouths you know
when we praise him we can be glorifying
God in our words as well so that's uh I
know that's broad but it's one of those
words that uh it's a glorious word hope
that helps a little bit Glenn by the way
I I've got a little book it's called the
two witnesses and it talks about the
Glorious Mount and this is where God's
glory is revealed on the mountain to
Peter James John and Jesus is
transfigured and it discusses that a
little bit to receive the book just call
and ask for it the number is 8835 6747
you can ask for the book it's called The
Glorious Mount or do pound 250 on your
smartphone say bye answers live and say
I'd like the book The Glorious mouth you
know Pastor Doug we beginning a lot of
folks are actually doing that they just
dialing pound 250 and they get the free
offer right there it's easy easy number
to remember next caller that we have is
uh Dwayne listening from Georgia Dwayne
welcome to the
program hey good evening gentlemen uh
evening I'm just a little bit nervous
here I apologize uh thank you for taking
my call and uh I certainly appreciate
your ministry yeah thank you just relax
don't worry
well you're great guys I'm just really
excited to talk to you uh I got a
question about the Sabbath uh is it a
friend of mine is telling me that uh he
he believes that we have lost sight of
the true
Sabbath uh through Babylon I don't know
if you've ever heard of this before uh
either one of you uh he claims that the
Sabbath days fall on the same days of
the month uh like the 15th the 22nd and
the 29th and that uh
they are always following like the three
months in a row that follow a new moon
cycle have you ever heard of anything
like this and is it I I just find it
hard to believe that God would ever let
us lose sight of his true day of worship
yeah that that's a um that's a teaching
that I think is very unbiblical it's
called the lunar Sabbath and they they
think that we're to pick the weekly
Sabbath based upon the lunar cycles but
there's really nothing in the Bible that
I find that teaches that that the
Sabbath always was based on a numerical
weekly cycle of 1 through 7 1- 7 1
through 7 that has continued in
continuity from Adam to the present day
and there are people that have written
the US Naval Observatory in the
observatory in Greenwich England and
said there have been any change to the
calendar that has affected the
continuity of the weekly cycle and they
say the weekly cycle has gone back in
continuity since long before the
Christian era and you know the Jews have
been tracking it um ever since uh The
Exodus when you know it goes all the way
to Adam because God creates the first
Sabbath on the seventh day in Genesis
chapter 2 and then it says Abraham kept
my laws and my commandments so you know
the the Jews were keeping it they lost
it in Egypt or they started ignoring it
God got them back on track again when he
started reigning Mana from Heaven says
you're going to get six days a week
you'll get enough for one day on Friday
gather enough for two days because the
next day is a Sabbath and there won't be
any on that day and so uh you God very
clearly for 40 years reestablished what
that cycle was and it was 1 through
seven had nothing to do with the moon so
I've heard that before and it I think
you really have to torture your logic to
say that the sabbaths are governed by
the moon and then we know that Jesus
according to the gospels he kept the
Sabbath as his custom was and that was
2,000 years ago and since then we have a
whole nation
that has been at least aware of which
day of the week is the Sabbath maybe
have the Jews haven't all kept the
Sabbath but they know which day is the
Sabbath and it's been uh kept ever since
so there should be no doubt yeah all
right thank you next caller that we have
is Lee in Texas Lee welcome to the
program yes sir thank you for taking my
call
tonight yes sir and how can we help you
well I'm not I'm not sure if I'm
supposed to ask this question but I
guess I can ask anyway and see if I if I
am wrong um there are six six chapter so
the Pope's encyclical lato SE uhhuh what
happens when all six are
done you mean when they're
implemented yes sir yeah well you know
the popes have had encyclicals for you
know 1500 years uh and it it'll lay out
the the ideals that they want I don't
know that any Pope has ever seen all of
it fulfilled and uh the L say um uh
encyclical that Pope Francis wrote and I
understand he's coming up with a a 2.0
version of it it's it's been updated or
expanded that it was unique in that it
especially focused on the
environment and um folks are interested
to see you know how is it going to
implement this well so far you know he's
campaigned for um changes and things
that would affect global warming and but
he you know he certainly hasn't been
able to implement all the changes that
he had as I ideals in his letter but it
does tell us the the important thing
about when the pope issues an encyclical
IT reveals kind of what their desired
agenda is and so this one was very
interesting because it was unique in
that I think Francis became the first
pope that really said uh that you know
the Christians need to focus on saving
the planet instead of moral change it
was making you know environmental issues
a moral issue so that was interesting
we'll be back in just a few moments so
don't go anywhere more question
questions are
[Music]
coming stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
shortly when I was 8 years old I brought
home a 5ft rattlesnake and it's gone
downhill ever since rattlesnakes sharks
cliff diving free diving I wouldn't call
myself an adrenaline J junkie I just
realized that the closest that I've ever
been to being alive is when I'm so close
to death I was raised in the northern
mountains of Mexico I learned English
because there was there was missionary
groups that were coming from Colorado
and then going to the northern mountains
of Mexico and uh they were all changed
on these short-term mission trips and
they had these unbelievable experiences
and they close encounters with God and I
would share their testimony I would
translate for them and uh
I was jealous I was jealous
because I didn't have a testimony I
didn't have something like that I didn't
have that life-changing experience that
that that close encounter with God I
knew he was there I
just I I couldn't understand him and I
didn't really want anything to do with
him and
and part of me wanted him not to want
anything to do with me I felt like I was
Unworthy of God's love I
left Mexico to come to college once I
got to college I realized how expensive
college was and so in order to pay for
college I became a commercial salmon
fisherman in Alaska and the first time
that I stepped on a boat I knew I was
going to be a fisherman for the rest of
my life I met this man in in Tennessee
in in one of the rivers and I found out
that he had an orphan engine in in
Honduras and he said you know you can
come down to Honduras you can help us
put a support video together and uh
and you know I was like maybe you can
get some college credits out of it I
said you know that that would be great I
would do that I would love to do that
and so I flew down to Honduras and uh
one of the conversations that we had
during
dinner we were talking about this and
that and somehow I brought up Rapture
and they said well find us a place in
scripture where it talks about Rapture
and I said it's all over the Bible I
said is it really though so they gave me
a DVD that said amazing facts and I
remember coming back to America and uh I
started watching and I said amazing
facts presents and Doug Basher started
talking one of the things that he said
is that the word rapture wasn't in
scripture and that was the first time
that I I actually heard Pastor Bachelor
speak and then I run into
YouTube a video series called prophecy
code and I said oh this is going to be
good
sweet but it was just
torture because everything I knew was
just getting tossed out the window he
was just using
scripture after
scripture to take away everything and
all everything that I thought was normal
and everything that I knew about about
the book of
apocalypses ever since I've learned
scriptural truth and I've seen the light
I feel like there's been a fire
rekindled in in my heart and I have this
knowledge that I want to share with
people it brings me peace and I think
that it does that for other people we've
managed to share with my name is Andrew
I am a fisherman and a
dreamer I want to thank you for changing
my
[Music]
life you're listening to Bible answers
live where every question answered
provides a clearer picture of God and
his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for get practical answers about
the good book for a better life
today this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live and if you've tuned
in somewhere along the way this is a
live International interactive Bible
study and you can participate you can
call in with a Bible question and that's
800 God says uh you can not only listen
on this radio station you may be
listening to but uh it's streaming live
if you want to see the video you can go
to the amazing facts Facebook page The
Amazing Facts YouTube page the Doug
Bachelor Facebook page and uh I think
we're streaming live on AFV and a number
of other stations so tell your friends
if you don't have any tell your enemies
to tune in and give us a call with a
Bible question and I think Pastor Ross
we're gonna oh that's right I'm Doug
Bachelor and I'm John Ross and we're
going to go back to the phone there you
go we got Michael listening in Florida
Michael welcome to the program good even
evening pastors how are you guys doing
evening well I guess I just want to be
candid um I've been blessed like with my
faith for the past few years
now um but the thing is um one of the
things for some for whatever reason has
been kind of besetting for me is the
doctrine of of hell I guess and I just
wanted to ask what does the bible teach
about um the ultimate fate of the wicked
because you know I I was raised to
believe in the doctrine of annihilation
that God ultimately destroys the wicked
but some time ago uh probably a couple
weeks ago I had like some bad dream
about sort of like the eternal torment
form of hell yeah and
um to to be quite honest it's you know
rattled you a little bit huh yeah it
rattled me it's it's uh robbed me some
sleep it's really like you
know all just thrown off my P so let's
we go yeah I understand Michael first of
all um don't worry about hell if you're
planning on going to
heaven so in other words I don't want to
give you comfort that hell won't be so
bad so you can go there the idea is you
want to be in the other place no matter
what and then you don't have to worry
either way but let me tell you what the
Bible says and hopefully it'll not only
bring some comfort but I think it brings
some reason the there's two extremes
that people make when it comes to
misunderstanding the subject of Hell one
is that nothing happens to the wicked
and the other is this kind of medieval
idea that God broils and and burns
people for billions of years and they've
never they never stopped burning for the
sins of one lifetime that's also not
true the Bible says the penalty for sin
is death Revelation says the wicked will
be
consumed uh you read in Malachi chter 4
it says they will be burnt up uh it says
you will diligently consider his place
and it will not be it says you will
tread down the wicked they are ashes
Under The Souls of your feet that's also
in Malachi um says the Lord the penalty
for sin of course is death the gift of
God is eternal life God does not give
eternal life to the
lost they are everyone is cast in the
Lake of Fire that is lost the Lost are
cast into the Lake of Fire everyone is
punished according to his works if
everyone Burns forever they all get the
same punishment everyone is punished
according into his works and they are
consumed the Bible uses the words
consumed devour burnt now they are burnt
with eternal fire what that means is the
result of the fire is eternal the Bible
says the fate of the wicked is the same
as Sodom and gomorah Sodom and Gomorrah
God reigned fire upon them they were
burnt they've never been rebuilt they
were burnt with eternal fire and so
those cities aren't there anymore and
they're not still burning and I you know
we have a whole study on this I could go
on and on but I think it'll bring BR you
comfort but the Bible is really clear
that God is fair and just in dealing
with the wicked um there is a hell there
is fire but it does not burn forever and
ever you know we got a website called
helltruth.com and it's got all the
scriptures there it's actually got the
lesson you're referring to as well
Pastor D and for anyone wondering what's
going to happen and why is this
important well I think first of all as
you said you know for the redeemed
they're going to be in heaven that's
where we want to be but uh the idea of
an eternal burning hell
for you know forever for somebody
suffering um just because of their life
of sin that's a reflection on the
character of God would a loving God do
that I think that Doctrine a
misunderstanding of of this of this
Doctrine has led countless Millions to
turn away from God saying well I don't
want to serve a god like that that's
going to torture people throughout
eternity that's what the Bible says yeah
absolutely so hopefully that helps a
little bit Michael and be careful not to
let the devil frighten you with dreams
because uh that's really not the source
of Truth we can have all kinds of dreams
we have a study guide called is the
devil in charge of hell that actually
answers all of these questions in
addition to the website just
helltruth.com you can call and ask for
that study guide the number is 800
47 and uh say ask for it is the devil in
charge of hell you can also dial pound
250 on your smartphone and just say
Bible answers live and then ask for that
study guid we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks we got Cammy
in California Cammy walking to the
program good evening pastors thank you
very very much for taking my phone call
this evening my question um it's
regarding Matthew 5:48 which says be ye
therefore perfect even as your father
which is in heaven is perfect so what is
meant by Perfect especially in light of
all of our righteousness being as filthy
rags in Isaiah
646 yeah that is a good question because
um you know people are thinking
wow if if I've got to be that kind of
perfect how can I do that I I think part
of the answer would be always compare
scripture with scripture when Jesus uses
that same phrase in Luke and if you look
in Luke chapter 6 verse
36 he says therefore be merciful as your
father in Heaven is
merciful and so the word perfect that he
uses in Matthew is a word be
mature
and here Jesus he says be merciful god
wants us to have a perfect love and
mercy for other people if the idea of
being perfect means that we all needed
to be some sort of super sterilized
stainless steel of Christians that you
know are are flawless nobody's going to
make it um God wants us to have perfect
love and if we love him we'll keep his
Commandments right so whenever I find
out when I want to know what is
Christian Perfection I just look at the
stories in the Bible of the faithful and
I know Elijah's in heaven I want to be
like him well the Bible says Elijah was
a man subject to like passions as we are
but he he prayed and God answered his
prayers I want to have the kind of Faith
Daniel had where he said I love the Lord
so much that I'd rather go to the Lion's
Den than disobey him or the faith of
Shadrach mesek and Abednego or Peter
James and John who will be in heaven but
they were arguing with each other about
which of them was the greatest they were
human and so you know God wants us to
keep our eyes fixed on Jesus to be like
him uh be born again to have that
Christian Perfection hopefully that
helps a little bit sometimes I remember
I first read that and it said be perfect
even as the father is perfect and I
thought wow not only that you read in I
think it's first Peter he says be holy
as I am Holy I think how am I ever going
to be as perfect and holy as God well
the only way that happens is if God
washes us from our sin and gives us his
spirit and his character so we reflect
his image so it's the Born Again
experience he's talking about you know
also think just want this is uh when
Jesus says be perfect even as your
father in Heaven is perfect it's it's
it's more of a promise than a command
because how can someone who is imperfect
be perfect but there is a promise that
God is able to do that which we cannot
do for ourselves yeah so to be perfect
is a gift of God it is the spirit of God
working within us we are to cooperate
but in reality it is the working of God
all right thank you for your call we've
got Noah listening in Kentucky Noah
welcome to the
program hey Pastor Doug hi my question
is if you sell your soul uh to Satan and
get something in return uh can you
repent and return to God and still go to
heaven or or is is it over is it final
you know like yeah that's a good
question so if you make a deal with the
Devil and you promise you make a vow can
you break a vow made to the devil I
would say yes because otherwise that
would be the unpardonable
sin um so I mean there's a lot of
examples in the Bible of people that uh
were serving the devil and uh God
transformed him you got you know King
Manasseh that he was sold out worshiping
pagan gods but he was converted he
repented and so to to make a vow to the
devil is a sin so can God forgive sin
yes he'll forgive that sin first of all
the sin of breaking a promise to the
devil secondly even dealing with the
devil but yeah don't fall into that trap
of thinking well I made a promise to the
devil and he gave me what I wanted now
I'm I'm lost repent of what you did and
uh let me give you an example maybe it's
not a good one but sometimes when we're
desperate we do things and I think God
knows you're just not in your right mind
I was hitch hiking one time and praying
for a ride and hours went by and I
couldn't get a ride and I thought I was
going to die out in the desert on this
freeway and I rashly promised I said
Lord if you'll give me a ride I promise
if I ever get a car I will pick up every
hitchhiker that I see I was tired and
hungry and and so I made this kind of a
rash promise well I tried when I first
got my car to pick up every hitchhiker
and then as time went by I realized this
is absurd I couldn't do it and I just
said Lord you know that was foolish and
I hope you'll forgive me but that
doesn't mean a Christian shouldn't keep
their promises but I think sometimes we
we do things like that and God Winks at
our ignorance do you know the Bible says
that I don't know if I should say this
the Bible says that if a wife makes a
vow the husband can overrule it yeah and
uh have you ever Tred to
overrule uh when your wife makes yeah
but I was three weeks in the hospital
[Laughter]
no yeah yeah I think I I've I don't call
it overruling don't use that word I say
hey Ken let's talk about that all right
new subject thanks hope that helps a
little bit next caller that we have is
Aaron listening New York Aaron welcome
to the program you're on the
air great evening pastors thank you for
taking my call yeah in in First
Corinthians 5:8 Paul says let us keep
the feast by I don't see the word Feast
mentioned anywhere else in the chapter
my question is what is the meaning of
the of this Bible
verse yeah well he's he talks in verse
six he talks about do you not know a
little leav Lev's the whole lump he's
making a reference that all the Jews
understood and I suppose the Corinthian
Christians did about the Passover they
were not to have any leav in their bread
and Len here is a symbol of sin that's
why Jesus told the disciples Beware of
the leaven of the Pharisees sin or false
Doctrine and so then he says let us
therefore keep the feast not with the
old leaven of malice and wickedness but
with the unleavened so later and I think
it's is it first or 2 Corinthians he
talks about the Passover that may be
rather the Lord's Supper that may be
second Corinthians but anyway I think
the listeners understood that he's
talking about um the Passover as a
symbol of Salvation the angel of
judgment passes over because of the
blood of the Lamb so they understood
that and I think also part of the
controversy in in the Old Testament or
actually in the New Testament I should
say in Corinth was you had the Jewish
Believers and then you had the Gentile
Believers and the Jewish Believers were
telling the Gentile Believers that they
had to keep all of the laws of the Old
Testament related to the ceremonial laws
yeah and the Passover and so on Paul is
almost saying here that if you're going
to keep the feast it says therefore let
us keep the feast not with old leaven
nor with the leaven of malice or
wickedness but with the unliving bread
of sincerity and truth so he's even
going a little bit deeper and saying
it's not about about the the keeping of
the feast meaning removing the leaven
from the house but rather there's a
spiritual application that he's trying
to bring to view have leav out of your
heart it has just like you says Jesus is
our Passover we don't keep the Passover
we it's spiritual spiritual application
of it yeah thank you good question Erin
all right next caller that we have is
har uh Henry in New York Henry welcome
to the
program yes hello Pastor uh God bless
you uh my question is uh when Jesus
Christ com back and
for the women who were pregnant and
their fade will the babies born in
heaven all right that's a great question
I remember I was doing a uh a Bible
answer one time on TV and the pastor
read the question that what's going to
happen to women who are pregnant when
Jesus comes and I said well they'll be
delivered so um I you know I assume that
uh either they would get their glorified
bodies and have a painless birth in
heaven because in the Garden of Eden
there was no pain in
childbirth um but I'm I'm more inclined
to believe that uh when they get their
glorified bodies the little baby's going
to be placed in their arms as a a new
baby um again there's a lot of things
that we speculate about you know people
say what's going to happen to folks that
are on the International Space Station
when Jesus
comes so you'll get all kinds of
um odd scenarios that are kind of hard
to comprehend but I don't worry about
that but yeah if a woman's saved and
she's pregnant when Jesus comes she can
be sure that she'll either have a
painless birth in heaven or those angels
will hand her that life uh with her
glorified
body absolutely all right next caller
that we have calling from Nevada and uh
dellan is that correct dnel d thank you
thank you for taking my call um my
question is in Matthew 12 12 43 to 45
talking about when an unclean Spirit
goes out of a man and goes through Dry
places seeking rest and finds none then
he says I return to my house much I came
and when he comes he finds it empty and
slapped and put in order then he goes
and takes with him seven other Spirits
more wicked than
himself and and um I my question
is are the evil are the spirits are the
evil
angels different levels of wickedness
well I think they probably could be
um well I think that we've learned that
even among the good Angels it seems like
there's different ranking and so there
might be some evil angels that are more
powerful which would make them more
effectively Wicked a Angels every one of
them they are created and they're
individuals and you know they have
different personalities just as people
do the good angels are all holy the bad
angels are all bad but they're unique
they're not like Cookie Cutter robots
and so I suppose when Jesus said he'll
take with him some that are even more
wicked that there are varying degrees
among the evil angels well you know we
noticed that even in the um experience
that Jesus had remember one occasion a
man brought his son to Christ and he was
demon possessed and the disciples
couldn't cast The Devils out yeah and
then Jesus said well this kind comes out
with prayer and fasting so there does
seem to be some kind of rank or power
yeah than than others which
yeah interesting so yes and I think that
the the most important part of that uh
Parable and it is a parable is Jesus is
saying if you come to him and the devils
are cast out and you're forgiven of your
sins replace that in your life with
something good if you don't introduce
the light of the truth in your life
eventually the darkness comes back and
it can seem even darker it's like where
Peter said if someone or it's Hebrews
rather in chapter is it chapter 4: 6 or
6 ver4 where he said if someone turns
away from the truth uh the latter state
of that man is worse in the beginning
Peter says it's like the dog returning
to his vomit or the pig that was washed
a wallowing in the Meer and in Hebrews
it says it's impossible to renew them to
repentance and so it's like the the grip
of the devil doubles if you turn back
it's not that you can't be saved but it
can be more
difficult okay next quer that we have is
Michael listening California Michael
welcome to the
program thank you uh had a question for
you about the feast days uh Leviticus 23
they're listed right there and the first
three verses are talking about the
Sabbath the weekly Sabbath right now
I've been keeping these days since
1975 and I I don't know who to ask about
this but I'll I'll throw it at you uh
those weekly sabbaths on the thir on
first three verses should be included in
the New Year correct as you have the day
of atonement you have Feast of trumpets
and all that God lists them from that
point
on and uh it's based on the Spring
Equinox the the 10th day you select the
the the lamb and the 14th day you kill
him let me and you sacrifice him yeah
let me pause you for a second just to
make sure I'm understanding are you are
you are you asking if we should be
keeping the annual feasts because the
the Sabbath in verse three is a weekly
feast and the other ones mentioned in
chapter 23 are the annual feasts that's
correct so you wondering if we should
keep them the same there should be in
the same year that that would mean that
there would be a new calendar every year
because those days change and instead of
using the uh Gregory Pope calendar the
yeah well the Gregorian the Gregorian
calendar had nothing to do with the
Jewish feast days that didn't come
around until that's correct J yeah right
well juliia Caesar is the Julian
calendar and then later you had the Pope
Gregory updated the Julian calendar and
that's why we're now living under the
Gregorian but neither of those had
anything to do with Leviticus they they
lived long before Leviticus is long
before the Caesars um so just yeah let
me count the days though okay go ahead
yeah let me just jump in here now and
um what's happening in Leviticus 23 is
Moses is going through the annual feasts
he begins by separating the weekly
Sabbath and saying of course 6 days your
work will be done the seventh day is the
Sabbath a holy convocation you gather
together in all your dwellings that's a
weekly cycle that was part of creation
part of God's perfect plan it says in
Heaven from one Sabbath to another All
Flesh will come and worship before the
Lord and so that's a memorial of
Salvation it's a memorial of creation
the levitical annual Feast did not
happen until after 2,000 years after sin
or even more than that because it was
after um Moses after The
Exodus and they were nailed to the cross
you if someone wants to keep them well
more power to you Paul said you know if
you're going to keep a day keep it to
the Lord if you're not going to keep it
don't keep it he's talking about the
annual feasts because the Jewish
Believers were telling the Christian
Believers you have to keep Passover day
of Aton and Feast of Tabernacles and
they didn't uh they didn't have to uh
the the one that were still obligated to
keep is the one that's in the Ten
Commandments the annual feasts are not
part of the ten commandments so we do
have a book that talks about the should
Christians keep the feast days and we'll
be happy to send you a copy of that
Michael you know just to add to that
quickly Pastor you know I think it might
be confusing sometimes the ceremonial
sabbaths were referred to as sabbaths so
you have the sixth day you know every
seven seventh day Sabbath but then you
have the annual Sabbath the the feast
days were to be commemorated like a
Sabbath and in other words they went to
work on that day and it was a gathering
a holy convocation which occurred also
on the seventh day Sabbath so when you
see the word Sabbath it could refer to
the seventh day Sabbath or it could be
referring to one of those ceremonial
sabbaths and that's why you need to you
need to figure out is just an annual day
that it's talking about or it's the
weekly day and that's the distinction
some were ceremonial part of the
levitical law the weekly Sabbath was
part of the Ten Commandments and it had
a very practical application for all
people at all time and even the animals
were to be given a day of rest so um
just want to make sure that we're
separating the two out and I think
Michael was saying that he thought we
should still be under an obligation to
keep both so we do have that book it's
called the feast days and Sabbath we'll
be happy to send it to anyone who calls
and ask the number is 800 835
6747 or you can dial pound 250 on your
smartphone Let's see pday we might have
time for one or two more callers let's
try for uh we got got Thomas in New York
Thomas welcome to the
program hello how you doing thank my
call um there's a lot of stuff on intern
I hear about you know Ellen G white try
to pict the end of the world will Miller
and he say ell white for Propet you know
went V how do I address this what they
they say toly when they try to predict
the second coming of Christ like how
what should I tell them elen white never
predicted the second coming of Christ uh
Ellen White was uh one of many
um Christians in the 18th 19th century
that uh were in the millerite movement
and the millerite movement was believing
that Christ was coming in
1844 but uh she did not predict that and
uh actually later said that was a
mistake so um people that try to connect
the two it's just not accurate it was
William Miller that established that
date I don't think the Bible's quite
clear Pastor no man knows the day or the
hour so if anyone's trying to predict
when Jesus is coming well be aware yeah
and Ellen White said don't predict it no
one knows the day or the hour so
hopefully that anwers that do we have
half a question we yeah we got Robert in
Washington Robert real quick we got just
a few
minutes yeah real fast thank you for
taking the call on 1st Samuel 16 and
verse 16 and 23 it says an evil spirit
from God I didn't think that evil
spirits came from God if you could
explain that to you I appreciate it
thank you very much
yeah good question um probably the best
way to understand that is when you read
the book of Job the devil was asking
permission to prove that job wasn't
really loyal to God and God had to
basically uh lengthen the devil's leash
or allow him to do it so you might say
well God sent the devil to job you know
God every good and perfect gift comes
from God God allowed job to be tested to
a certain point uh to demonstrate his
faith and even strengthen his faith but
it was the devil that did it it was the
devil that initiated it and it's the
same thing that you're reading about
with King Saul Saul grieved away the
holy spirit because of his pride and
when you grieve away the light the only
thing that's left is Darkness the devil
came in as an evil spirit and filled
that vacuum and tormented the king so
the Hebrew uses kind of the old phrase
came from the Lord hey friends you've
asked some great questions tonight and I
just as time goes so quickly wish we had
more time Pastor Ross thank you so much
for studying the word of God With Us and
Lord willing we'll do it again together
next
week thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
[Music]
California
what if you could know the
future what would you
do what would you
change to see the future you must
understand the past Alexander the Great
becomes king when he's only 18 but he's
a military
prodigy 150 years in advance Cyrus had
been
named Rome was violent they were
ruthless they were determined this
intriguing documentary hosted by Pastor
Doug Bachelor explores the most striking
Bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history Kingdoms in
time are you
ready did you know that that Noah was
present at the birth of Abraham okay
maybe he wasn't in the room but he was
alive and probably telling stories about
his floating Zoo from the creation of
the world to the last day events of
Revelation bible.com is a free resource
where you can explore major Bible events
and characters enhance your knowledge of
the Bible and draw closer to God's word
go deeper visit the amazing Bible
timeline at
bible.com
the US government is drowning in debt to
the tune of$ 22 trillion but before you
wag your finger at the government's
spending the Federal Reserve says the
average American household carries over
$137,000 in debt well it was never God's
plan that we live with a burden of debt
Proverbs 22:7 warns us the rich rules
over the poor and the borrower is
servant to the lender living with debt
is a stressful burden that actually
hurts your relationship with God in my
new pocketbook deliverance from debt I
outline the Bible principles on how to
properly manage your money with some
practical suggestions on how you can get
out and stay out of debt if you or
someone you love is drowning in debt
order a copy of Deliverance from debt
today it can be a lifesaver to keep you
from going under please call 800 5387
275 or visit AF bookstore.com
[Music]
Hello friends for those of you who
stayed by we had to greet and say
goodbye to those listening on satellite
radio but for the rest of you we've got
your email questions that we like to
answer if you have a Bible question you
want to email to us it's just B
questions at amazingfacts.org
Pastor Doug question number one is Satan
an angel I know that he was a covering
cherub but is that the same as an
Angelic being well I think that he would
be in the category uh of angels and you
can read is it 2 Corinthians chapter 11
it says and no Marvel for Satan himself
is transformed into an angel of Light
well he's an Angel of Darkness but he
can look like an angel of Light so we
would categorize him as an angel does a
person need to be baptized to get to
heaven well we are not saved by virtue
of baptism I don't want to give the
wrong impression there there will be
people in heaven who are not
baptized uh but Christ is pretty clear
in the New Testament it says John the
Baptist was doing baptism and the last
words of Jesus are go teach baptize and
he said whoever believes in his baptized
will be saved and Peter said repent and
be baptized and you'll receive the gift
of the holy spirit so baptism is as
important to a Christian as a wedding is
to a marriage as so if a Believer can be
they must be all right then there's a
full on question it says um who then can
do the baptism can any other Christian
do the baptism or do they have to be a
licensed Pastor how does that work you
know it seems that in the Bible that
Jesus authorized certain leadership to
perform baptisms they were the very
least deacons but typically the apostles
and in Samaria when they accepted the
Lord they then sent John and Peter to
lay hin on them and so there was some
Authority designated making sure those
that were baptized were clearly
instructed in the gospel okay uh do we
know anything more about this the mark
that was placed on Cain after he killed
Abel you know that is something of an
enigma and pardon the play on words it
just says a mark and it's it's the word
is almost like you know something that
would be impressed or engraved but it
may have been a mark as though he was a
Marked Man there was some significant
difference or he had been marked by his
behavior and his record it's we really
don't know it doesn't say anything more
than what you read there in the text mhm
and of course you also find a mark in
Revelation yeah so there's an analogy
there uh last quick question pad why are
there Gates on the New Jerusalem if uh
there's no nothing evil outside Gates
aren't all bad to keep bad things out
gates are also borders to keep good in
and uh just gives us a a delineation
thank you so much again for your
questions God bless we'll study again
together next
week bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible
questions